derrick henry the titans running back
has signed his franchise tender he's
under contract for 2020 at a base salary
of 10.2 million at look it requires him
to show up for everything but there's
not going to be an off season program so
there's nothing to show up for
anyway he is uh guaranteed his money
assuming there's a football season and
now they can continue to discuss a
long-term deal peter through july 15 and
john robinson the gm and the titans has
said that they will continue to try to
turn this one-year contract into a
long-term arrangement
i can understand why derrick henry uh
and his agents would say
okay you know we're glad to have this
insurance policy
the only way we're signing a long-term
deal
is if we get a real legitimate contract
we understand the running back story in
the nfl today they're not paid the way
running backs always have been paid
but mike i'll just say this
you know
i don't know watching any running back
in the last few years in the nfl i don't
know any of them even the ones who've
gotten paid lightly you know like
devante freeman tell me what running
back has been worth a big second
contract truly worth a big second
contract i mean a big contract you just
haven't seen it and that's why i
understand you look at you look at henry
now and you say oh my god we got to keep
him we got to pay him i i tread a little
lightly there and if i were the
tennessee titans i wouldn't mind at all
if he played this year under the tender
and we didn't sign him long term and one
other thing if i'm derek henry
i would look at this if i could get four
years and ratchet up the guaranteed
money to maybe
22 or 25 and i know that his ages are
probably oh my god that's just not
enough
you know i think it might be enough in
the new post gurley running back
landscape
i think you're absolutely right peter i
can't think of a team that did that
massive second contract other than the
vikings who signed adrian peterson in
2011 to his second deal and he was the
league mvp in 2012 after tearing his acl
to cap the 2011 season most of these
guys recently when they get the second
contract or the big contract like
le'veon bell last year on the open
market the production isn't there and
it's maybe better to dangle that carrot
for another year for derrick henry yes
he's going to get paid a lot of money
but that lure of the long-term deal may
keep him moving in the direction that he
has been in recent years i i don't know
what the reason is i don't know if it's
wear and tear i don't know if it's
psychological or they feel like they've
they've reached their their goal and now
they can exhale and they're not as
effective after they do that but we
haven't seen great performance out of
running backs in recent years when they
get the second contract
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports